nous avons récupéré forte heureusement
benoît martin secrétaire général de
l'union départementale de la cgt paris
après une petite coupure de deux réseaux
ont parlé de cette plainte un revenant
martins avec vous pour mise en danger de
la vie d'autrui après l' incendie de
notre dame
la ville de paris je répète ma question
tout à l'heure en quoi est elle
responsable selon vous alors nous avons
porté plainte contre quiconque aurait
joué un rôle pour dire en termes de
négligence 1 par rapport à toutes les
expositions aux risques du plomb donc il
n'y a pas que la ville de paris qui est
visé il ya un certain nombre
d'employeurs du public comme du privé
il ya les autorités en général la ville
pourquoi pas la préfecture pourquoi pas
l'agencé régionale de santé le ministère
de la culture etc
le ministère du travail donc voilà il ya
tout un ensemble d'acteurs qui ont joué
un rôle et qui ont minimisé les risques
qui les ont même parfois nier un éthique
aurait être impliqué dans cette affaire
mais nous notre dépôt de deux plaintes
visent en général tous les acteurs qui
auront fait preuve de négligence il ya
eu des alertes qui n'ont pas été assez
présent contre c'est bien cela oui alors
les les alertes ont émané non seulement
de notre collectif constitué de
syndicats cgt de deux associations
et puis des parents également des
familles des parents d'élèves un parmi
les plaignants il ya la société une
association mais également de deux
familles dont les enfants ont des taux
devront eu des taux de plomb dans dans
le sens extrêmement élevé donc oui il y
a eu des négligences
il ya eu un déni de la gravité de cette
pollution ou clos 1 les 400 tonnes qui
ont été répandues dans l'atmosphère sous
forme de poussières sont retombés voilà
et ont contaminé les gens donc
évidemment toutes les alertes qui ont eu
lieu ont été magnifiques
de notre collectif mais également de
l'inspection du travail l'inspection du
travail avait quand même rendu un
rapport l'été 2010 9
j'ai conduit est bien au fait que le
chantier avait été au suspens durant l
été 2010 neuf noms des deux alertes il y
en a eu de très nombreuses pourquoi il
n'y a pas eu de confinement total du
chantier comme c'était d'ailleurs
demandé un parler les associations les
ouvriers n'ont pas été assez protégés ou
non plus voilà exactement un compliment
de l'édifice l'autre dame était tout à
fait possible